welcome to another realistic non-diet
what aena day as a dietitian started
with my soy milk latte of course then I
made some oatmeal with some protein
powder in there added some peanut butter
for healthy fats lots of berries some
hemp Parts on top it is so satiating and
so yummy love it for lunch I did a
Sourdough sandwich with some pesto lots
of avocado for healthy fats egg chicken
put some cheese on there we loaded it up
it was a big sandwich and I served that
with hummus some carrots and and some
strawberries poppy enjoyed it too for
dinner we ordered in I had a vegan udon
noodle soup and some edamami I'm
obsessed with that of Mommy I ate the
whole thing it's so good and for a
bedtime snack I dove into the Lays
family siiz bag of ketchup chips with
some cottage cheese cereal and fruit yum